you're a pizza delivery person for a
company we're not at liberty to name
it may seem like a thankless job but
you're part of the thin crust
between satisfaction and starvation for
people who really don't feel like
cooking or going out tonight
you're a tried and true pizza veteran
you've seen a lot on the job
from people who try to rob you on their
own doorsteps to one guy who tried to
tip you with a clearly fake
rolex but you haven't seen anything like
the insanity
you're about to encounter tonight that's
because you're about to get sick
really really sick and we know there's
probably a lot of diseases you'd rather
not catch
but trust us no disease bites quite like
scp-3760 but back to you
you're parked on the saddle of your
prized bicycle pedaling for your life
the biggest order you've ever delivered
strapped to the cargo rack behind you
eight large meat feast pizzas you figure
you're heading towards the most hopping
or at least the hungriest party in the
city
and despite the frustration of needing
to ferry this hot cheesy nightmare to
its destination
parties have historically been pretty
good tippers little do you know
your prized customer is about to give
you much more than just a tip
you pull outside their ground level
apartment and park your bike
there's no music coming from the
apartment you're heading to
strange you pick up your precious cargo
and trudge towards the door
barely managing to ring the bell with
your spare pinky
the door swings open instantly as though
the occupant was
just standing behind it the whole time
waiting for you
when the door opens you're not sure what
to make of what you see
inside there isn't a party there doesn't
even seem to be a group
just one person standing there and
staring at you and something about this
person is just
wrong his skin seems to be an oddly
unnatural color
it has a slightly gray hue like it's
rotting
and you see that the stranger shirt is
torn in several places
you're trying your best to remain
professional and not stare
but you'd notice that whatever is under
these tears doesn't look like
skin it's almost like there are holes
all over his body underneath the shirt
big gaping holes and are those
you're cut off when he takes the pile of
pizzas from you and shoves what was once
a handful of dollars into your palm
they seem torn up and worst of all wet
you look past your strange customer and
see that his apartment looks just
as shoddy as he does there's stuffing
torn from the couch
huge tears in the curtains what you
could swear are scratch or bite marks on
some of the wooden furniture
this man clearly needed his pizza as you
begin to step away happy to just be rid
of this freaky situation
you do something that you'll live to
regret just for a moment
you lock eyes with the customer there's
something about them that makes you feel
sick they're wet and black more like a
doll's eyes than anything that should
belong
to a human just that one instant of
contact is enough to chill your bones
and according to some theories around
scp-3760
it may have been the moment of your
infection as the stranger closes the
door in your face
presumably to eat his obscene number of
pizzas you stumble back to your bicycle
letting your torn up gooey tip blow away
in the wind
getting out of this place is rewarding
enough but you can't chase the thoughts
of the stranger out of your mind
was he sick was he even human these are
the thoughts swimming through your head
as you cycle back to the restaurant
you're so preoccupied you don't even
notice the truck speeding towards you
you get sideswiped destroying your bike
and throwing you in the air
you can feel the snap of your arm
breaking as you land
it's a horrible feeling to go along with
the horrible noise
and as you fade from consciousness the
last thought in your mind is the black
soulless
eyes of the customer when you wake up
you'll find that you're in a hospital
bed with your arm and a cast
the doctors tell you that you're
phenomenally lucky to be alive given the
severity of the crash
the doctor says that you're dealing with
a compound fracture in your right arm
as well as some nasty cuts that required
stitches but
otherwise you're fine the hospital
insists that you at least stay the night
though
and you oblige but that night you find
it's difficult to sleep partially
because of the pain
but mostly because of an extremely
strange sound coming from inside the
cast around
your arm it's a scraping noise like
something sharp scratching at the
interior
you figure it must just be some strange
side effect of the pain meds
you're not going to let worry eat you up
on the inside
something else will be doing that soon
enough
you're discharged from the hospital the
next day and told that you should be
fine in a couple of months
as though that's some kind of
consolation you try to carry on with
your daily life
as much as you can with one arm out of
commission but that awful crunching
noise from inside your cast
persists you even start to become
paranoid that some sort of insect is
trapped inside
or worse a swarm of insects
but you aren't left with that
uncertainty for long by the next morning
your cast has fallen off
well not fallen per se a more accurate
description would be that it was
chewed off from the inside and not by
something trapped in there with your arm
but by your arm itself when you finally
see it it doesn't even look like an arm
anymore
the flesh has turned gray that same
sickly gray of the customer's skin
the night of your accident but worse
still from the top of the hand down to
the base of the forearm
your entire arm is split open into a
fang
lying chattering mouth when you've
gotten over the initial horror of seeing
the mutations that have taken hold of
your arm
you notice something about the teeth in
the second mouth they're nothing like
human teeth
they're vicious jagged triangles each
one like a dagger
these are unmistakably shark's teeth
you give yourself the luxury of having a
good screen after all what else are you
supposed to do after you find your arm
has turned into some kind of fleshy
shark mutant you notice that you can
hardly even feel the snapping of its
jaws
like it isn't even really a part of you
and as much as you try to tense and
release what used to be the tendons in
your forearm
there is no change for all intents and
purposes
that limb is no longer yours it just
happens to be attached to you
not only that but it's always very very
hungry
as quickly became evident from the fact
it made such short work of the cast that
had been containing it
not long ago you can see that the
graying flesh is beginning to spread
from your forearm to your bicep
it's almost like little by little your
tissue is being
switched somehow you're innately aware
that if you don't feed your arm
it'll get even worse suddenly everything
about the strange customer from the
night of the accident makes
sense he had whatever you have now only
worse
he was just hoping that the pizzas would
keep the beast at bay
and you very much hope the contents of
your fridge will do the same
wasting no time you grab some processed
ham and raw chicken
you're not an idiot you know that if
this thing is anything like a real shark
it's only going to be interested in meat
but when you shove the processed meat
into the nibbling maw in your forearm
you notice that it seems to spit the
food out something tells you
that your offering was too dead
now you're really afraid will this thing
want life prey
will that be the only way to stop it
from taking the rest of your arm or even
more
the thought terrifies you it's like
being venom
except you don't even get a new alien
friend or any cool super powers for your
trouble
but you're smart you're resourceful you
don't intend to let this thing take over
your life without a fight
and you've always believed what gi joe
taught you knowing
is half the battle sadly doing an
internet search for my injury is somehow
mutating into a shark how do i stop this
didn't do much good
and you don't want to go to a doctor
because part of you expects to be
immediately shipped off to the nearest
circus or
military research lab instead you throw
on a thick leather jacket that you hope
your new
shark arm will take a while to eat
through and head to the library of the
nearest medical college
if anywhere has sources on the most
obscure of medical problems
this would be the place and after hours
of searching through index cards
you find it what seems to be the one and
only source of this ludicrous topic in
the thousands and thousands of books
a series of journal entries made by dr
keith woodward
ship's medical officer aboard the uss
kirby circa 1922.
even the library's indexing system
prefaces the source with a disclaimer
that it's likely 25
quackery and 75 percent ocean madness
but that doesn't deter you any poured in
a storm
dr woodward told the horrifying tale of
the uss curvy's collapse due to a sudden
and unexplainable contagion it began
with the infection of a sailor on the
ship named willis riggs who'd fallen
overboard and had his foot partially
eaten by a shark
much like your arm the man's foot slowly
became the ravenous
all devouring mouth of a shark itself
little by little
it spread to the other crew members
through unknown means
any injuries sustained by the crew
didn't heal like normal
but instead became this vicious living
shark tissue
soon these ever-hungry new mouths led
them to eat each other
and then themselves from the inside out
even after the humans they once were
could be considered long
dead those hungry jaws kept snapping
there was no cure there was no solution
everyone on the boat was recorded as
having mysteriously died at sea
that is the curse of scp-3760
and as if on cue you look down to see
that the shark's mouth in your arm has
chewed through the leather of your
sleeve like it's nothing
it's hungry and nothing will satiate it
but perhaps some sacrifices need to be
made if you want to stop it from getting
worse
just as the thought crosses your mind a
needle full of sedative is injected into
your neck
everything goes dark very quickly and
when you wake up you're in a clean
clinical white room
you are now officially under containment
by the scp foundation
not that you'll know that anytime soon
this may seem like the calvary has
arrived
but sadly for your sake they have no
interest
in curing you they're just eager to
gather more data on how your condition
progresses scp-3760 exists as a latent
infection in well
over half of humanity but its horrific
mutating effects are activated
in only a relative few there have only
been 2785 recorded cases
of scp-3760 activity observed between
1958
and 2016. this is thanks to the
foundation's secret weapon against the
shark mutation menace
subliminal mimetic agent kappa omicron
or sma ko
a widely distributed mimetic agent that
suppresses the symptoms of infection in
most people
not that this would provide much comfort
to you as you join the almost 3000
others who have been infected
and you are doomed to slowly turn into
an abomination
in your containment chamber if it's any
consolation
you may not see the truly advanced
stages of the disease
the most common cause of death among the
afflicted is being eaten by their own
ravenous shark mouths
long before it changes your entire body
actually come to think of it
that's not much of a consolation at all
but hey when it comes to anomalous
mutations
we're sad to report that there's rarely
a happy ending in store for those
afflicted
and scp-3760 is no exception
to the rule now check out scp-4205 in
the eyes of the beholder
and scp-610 the flesh that hates for
more anomalous infections you really
don't want to catch